How does DevOps fit into the world
of software development, and
relate to things like
agile development and
continuous integration that
have been around for a while?
Agile software development is based
on iterative development, where
requirements and solutions evolve via
collaboration between self-organized and
cross-functional teams.
The term was coined in 2001 when
the agile manifesto was formulated, so
it's been around for
a bit longer than DevOps.
But in many organizations
using agile development,
not everybody has been
invited to the party.
There's a good chance that you already
use some form of agile development in
your organization.
But it covers just a couple of
steps in the whole process.
There are other steps
that need to be covered.
Agile development generally covers
the steps from planning to coding
to building and testing.
And then iterating on the design again.
It also emphasizes collaboration
between cross-functional teams.
Testing here includes unit testing of
code as well as integration testing and
user acceptance testing.
But agile doesn't necessarily
speak to release process.
And deployment and operation can look
very similar in an agile organization to
in a traditional software organization.
And that's not necessarily
the best solution.
When we start to improve this,
by automating build and
unit test processes, this is
covered by continuous integration.
The automation process helps with
the iterative development and
makes sure that changes or new features
do not break other functionality.
Automating it all the way to the release
is covered by continuous delivery.
Continuous delivery pipeline also makes
it easy to control user testing and
release the software
when all the tests pass.
Now, to make sure it's possible
to deploy all these releases
into production to thousands or
maybe millions of users,
there has to be an automated
scalable way to run operations.
And to make sure that
everything runs smoothly and
to improve the whole process over time
it's necessary to measure it all.
But for
that measurement to be actionable,
there has to be good communication and
a culture of sharing and
collaborating between
all the teams involved.
Adding automation to this system is
good, but it's only when you combine it
with a culture of communication and
collaboration between teams that you
really have the DevOps approach
to the software life cycle.